a family with a two-year-old and a
special needs child
was kicked off temporarily kicked off a
spirit airlines flight
they were eventually let back on
apparently but
that doesn't that doesn't make what
we're about to see here okay
and uh let's let's watch it here
i told you non-compliance you will have
to get off
i don't want to do this
what do we do
meanwhile both of the both of the adults
are wearing a mask
all we see there is the the toddler
who's by the way totally unbothered
that's what i like about toddlers she's
just sitting there
enjoying her yogurt completely oblivious
to everything
[Music]
yeah she's eating a yogurt and she's not
not only is she a toddler but she's also
in the process of eating
and so that's why she's getting singled
out
excuse me i'm not going to leave them
until i'm on fire all right
and then and then eventually they were
so they also have a special needs child
who you can't see in the video right now
but sitting in between the parents
there's a special needs child
uh a little bit older but he you know he
looks like he's i don't know how old he
is but
certain young he's a young child um they
were eventually kicked off the flight
forced to to get off the flight and then
they and then they were allowed to get
back on
after going through all of this
rigmarole and the uh
humiliation and all of that they were
eventually let back on
that that doesn't make this okay though
to harass a family
with young children and humiliate them
like this
only to let them back on it none of that
is okay i mean this is this is evil
behavior
and what i hate the most about it there
are so many things i hate about but
the worst thing and you can it's hard to
hear the audio but you can hear the
flight attendant there saying that hey
this is the policy there's nothing i can
do about it and yeah i i don't like it
either but
having these people hide behind policy
while they're you know harassing
families who aren't doing anything wrong
insisting that they muzzle their young
children for no reason
no no real medical reason just do it
because it makes everyone else feel
more comfortable allegedly and they hide
behind the policy
well you know policies are not these
uh you know like deities that are
hovering there
and and and can cause you to do things
you don't want to do
policies are just they're nothing unless
you have people to enforce them
a policy can't do anything unless people
enforce it
and so if you are choosing to enforce it
then you can't hide behind that policy
that's a choice that you are making
and meanwhile this is spirit airlines
like if this doesn't convince you to
stop flying spirit then i don't know
what will
because on top of this on top of them
harassing young families with young
children
uh they're also just one of the worst
companies
in existence
flying spirit airlines is a it's a even
compared to most other airlines and this
is saying something it's a
miserable experience they
spirit airlines they hate their
customers you can just tell they hate
you it's one of those things
and this is at every level in my
experience anyway
customer service if you have to call
them or you get on the flight the flight
attendants
everyone's in a bad mood they don't like
you they don't want you there
so it's a horrible service um
the the planes are cramped it's like
they're sticking you into these sardine
cans
and uh and on top of that they treat
their customers like crap as you just
saw there
but that's not enough to convince you
the thing is i would say i will happily
pay like 400
more to fly on a better airline
but all the other airlines are crap too
so or most of them anyway
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated